my name is Marc Sephora new I work on
numerix mostly I'm going to talk about
the run timeline but I'll describe what
that is I'll try and give you a little
bit of an overview of what it does and
I'll spend most of time talking about
the things that we've been doing to
develop it but most of what I've been
doing with iliyan who's sitting here in
the audience too so feel free to talk to
either us afterwards so what is the
runtime library so several years ago
when the compiler was rebuilt we moved a
lot of functionality out of the kernel
into a separate library and most of the
functionality that was moved out was
data structures M tensor which is the
heart of the packed array data structure
M sparse array which is the machine
sparse array data structure and
something new that was recently added is
this M R or array that you've seen
probably if you've been some audio talks
or things like that so you can support
different data formats with different
bit sizes etc it's the home of where
most of the machinery thematics scalar
and vector operations live the core
linear algebra operations the blasts a
basic linear algebra subroutines there's
also lots of other stuff random number
generation hashing functions hash tables
which don't have a user API but we use a
lot in the kernel thread safes memory
allocation and threads for scheduling
very very low-level functionality that
we don't really have API swarf for users
in the kernel but which are used a lot
throughout the computation of things
it's using them it's accomplished using
a mixture of C and a growing amount of
C++ code with some platform specific
optimizations and some special-purpose
libraries so I'll talk a little bit
about those the most significant
libraries that we use are this math
kernal library by Intel mainly for
linear algebra a lot of some vector
arithmetic and we're also using this
integrated performance primitives vector
arithmetic and some image processing
type of functionality we use them in a
mode where the results are in a sense
the slowest mode that's provided because
we
want things to be reproducible for one
session to another we don't want any
randomness in the results of things that
are being solved so we've added a lot of
new operations from IPP IPP adds a lot
of functionality that's not an MK open
for vector arithmetic so some of the
things that we've added some
trigonometric functions vector norms min
max total mean and the list goes on so
you if you do your operations using
packed arrays and a vectorized kind of
way you should get some kind of fairly
big speed-up I don't want to give you
lots of plots and things like that but I
just say something like a factor of 2
for min and Max up to a factor of 7 was
this for being typical so-so machine new
estimate weak operations in Mathematica
check for arithmetic exceptions when
you'd like 1 plus 1 it's not just
calling 1 plus 1 in a sea route een that
sure has to check if that one plus 1 can
fit into a machine integer ok every
single time you enter an operation
Mathematica is doing doing work to see
if the result that comes back still fits
into the same type or if it has to
dynamically change the type of the
expression and return a different result
so these functions are implemented
inside this runtime right B so that they
can be shared when you compile a code
through the the bytecode of the compiler
or if you generate C code even in
through a library they can be shared
between all these different function
functions and and implemented and
optimized in only one place that's the
important thing
so here's an example if I just take a
machine integer the maximum machine
integer and add one to it
Mathematica returns me an integer but
this is no longer a machine integer so
this addition here was carried out in
the runtime library it said are your
result has essentially wrapped around no
longer fits assigned in integer returns
an error status from the runtime library
and then we go and do something in in
arbitrary position and a similar kind of
thing happens in the compiler if you
compile that that code and you try and
add 1 to that number then what you get
is something like
this this error here the numerical error
was in Co and encountered at a certain
instruction so the flagging of this
error came from this this machine
arithmetic function from the runtime
library
okay so you can see a tiny snippet of
the runtime library when you generate C
code through the compiler okay if I from
that compile function that I had on the
previous slide if I use this C code
string generator to generate C code from
the compiler right down here tucked down
here in this black line here you'll see
a call to some obscure function i've
emitted a lot of a preamble code there
and and this is the function that's
called here
okay this obscure looking thing here and
this is the one that does the plus the
actual addition from the runtime library
that's linked into your code okay if I
switch off the overflow and underflow
detection and generate C code then what
I get is something that looks like this
it just calls the C it just calls the C
function here okay this is no longer
using the runtime lab it's just called
the calling the the C plus function okay
so it doesn't do this addition or error
checking it runs faster but the downside
is that you'll get a negative answer for
the results
and you can get another glimpse of this
runtime library when you compile stuff
the compilation target goes to see and
use the old compiler to generate C code
compile it link it to a library and link
that library back into the compile
function if you look inside that
compiled function you'll see this this
library function and this library
function is living on the top of
functionality that's built into this
runtime library that we use okay so
let's look at what what are the
advantages well this is a typical one in
a procedural type of language you write
something in an iterative way you just
some numbers in a loop over and over
again every single time you do some
operation here making data structures
and you're interpreting the operation
and there's a lot of overhead you're
having to go through the evaluator in
Mathematica etc which you don't want to
do it if you're doing a purely numerical
computation if you do things in a
different way here I make a pact array
essentially which is an array of machine
numbers then I can use vectorized
operations these vectorizer operations
total will be calling a vectorized
operation in the runtime library that
can go and sum up those things in a
vectorized very fast way okay so that's
where the efficiency comes from so let's
look at a little bit of the work we've
been doing to improve parallel
computation okay in parallel computation
there are very different ways of
scheduling jobs okay I'm only going to
look at vectors so let's take a vector
that has save 64 blocks ok I'm going to
chop it up into pieces each piece has
eight eight blocks of computation in it
and I'm going to give those pieces off
to a multi-core machine so in an ideal
world with no communication overhead
what's going to happen is I should hope
to get to be able to run eight of my
pieces of my vector or one core another
eight on another core another eight on
another core when I get an eight factor
of eight speed-up
okay and this is a very simplistic model
that ignores overhead for scheduling
communication and synchronization but in
the real world an idle machine is good
for benchmarking but it's not really
what we work with okay we might be using
a shared workstation something on the
cloud or we might have other processes
going on on our machine web browser
operating system the front end of
Mathematica we might be compiling some
code or something like that so what I've
done here is I've in my cause my eight
core machine these red blocks this is a
time sample these red blocks are busy
doing other operations okay so my my I
need to run eight blocks on each
processor but some of the processes are
busier than others okay so this is a
problem because the the cost of the job
is dominated by this busy by this busy
core okay and this is the kind of this
is a kind of partitioning that's used
for the vector operations in Mathematica
11 now the question is why don't we
often see such very bad behavior here
we've only got a factor of 2 instead of
a factor of 8 speed-up okay and the
reason is that the operating system will
often move some some thread to another
processor okay so it kind of saves us
from this worst case behavior and it
does it it does it like this when we're
moving along here we haven't done very
much of this suddenly another core
becomes completely free because it's
finished its job and the work that was
left here could be moved over here ok so
the operating system has 3 3 scheduled
some work and moved over to another core
and we've kind of got a much better
situation than the one we had before
where it is dependent on the slowest
core now the this is good but it's also
non-deterministic because there's no
guarantee that it could have moved that
particular thread to that particular
core it depends on on the workload of
the CPU and everything so here's another
scenario and the
time is slightly different here okay so
it really depends on the operating
system schedule which caused their idle
at which particular time what the
workload is etc etc etc so one of the
things that we've tried to do is to use
a more modern technique for work
scheduling called setting up a work list
and work sharing or stealing as it's
called sometimes and the idea is that
we'll just have a list of 64 blocks we
don't care which thread or which CPU
handles each one of those individual
blocks we don't care we just need to
know whoever's free at whatever time is
going to go and get one of those blocks
and go work on it and if we do that then
you see that we can compactify all of
the work to whatever is free at whatever
time each thread and it moves along can
take whatever block is next in the list
of that vector computation to do and it
can go and do it whenever it's ready as
soon as it's done it can go and get
another block off the list okay so and
then here we see that some of the other
threads took work that wasn't completed
that was originally tied to the first
thread so in a sense we're freeing up
one thread from doing work from another
thread okay and we can get a much a much
more reasonable speed-up put much closer
to the ideal of the factory rate and we
don't really rely on the operating
system scheduling moving our jobs around
for one process to another now the
challenge is how big a block of work
should we take we take a block of work
that's too small then we're going to
have a lot of communication overhead
between these threads and it's going to
be more than the actual work that's done
in the vector computation if we take too
big a block we're going to be back to
that situation where the slowest core
was dominating the entire time of the
computation so what we've done now is we
have in the new version of Mathematica
something that's going to interrogate
the processor on your machine and that
code is going to look at what kind of
- structure you have and it's gonna try
and say are the largest cash for you for
your CPU divided by the number of cores
is the amount of work that I'm going to
try and and I use that's my basic my
basic by quantum and so we select the
block size it's according to the size of
this cache per core and the number of
vector elements that's going to run in
that chunk depends on the type of
operation that we're doing if it's an
addition it needs two vectors in the
addition and a vector for the result so
where we have three vectors worth of
data to fit into that block so the
length of the vector being operated on
it's going to be slightly smaller if
it's something like total total is just
a single vector and accumulating a
scalar so we can use pretty much all of
the cache for that length of vector and
another advantage is a slightly
improvement in cache locality so just to
show you in practice this is the new
strategy that we have and this is the
old strategy that we had yeah in this is
in a machine that had 16 cores 8 cores
were busy with jobs that someone else is
running on the machine so it's quite
heavily loaded this machine ok so you
see that the new scheme can gain around
30% of execution time and as a
worst-case we'd expect here I have a
machine with 12 course it's completely
idle so in the worst case the old and
the new strategy should be should be
pretty similar but that's not the case
actually because sometimes the operating
system every so often does some kind of
task and so the new strategy even on an
idle machine ends up being just as good
and the communication overhead you can
see is it's just it's just negligible
here so another thing that we've done is
to look at machine integer instructions
so when we need to check for an integer
overflow something like multiplication
one integer times another integer
sometimes the only way to do it in C
code is to go and divide the result by
an integer to check that you haven't had
a wraparound of side but that means
you're doing a multiplication and a
division for every integer
multiplication so
that's more than twice the cost of the
operation so that's that's that's slow
we don't want to do that a lot of
compilers have what they call built-in
or intrinsic operations that allow you
to do that instruction and flag an error
saying it knows when it does this in its
in its CPU die if they spin some wrap
around or overflow and it read and it
will return that as a bit flag and it so
it's practically the same speed as just
doing an integer multiplication so if
you can have access to that lower level
functionality you can get something
integer multiplication or addition or
subtraction at the same speed as if it
was unchecked so that's what we've
implemented in the development version
here this is a machine with 4 physical
cores in the blue is Mathematica version
11 that's the execution time in the
orange is this platform specific
intrinsic compiler operation so you get
a factor of 2 here because you've
avoided doing a multiplication and
division it's pretty much a factor of 2
and the other thing that we've done is
implemented on top of that a
multi-threaded layer so we have now
integer machine integer Blas that can
run in parallel using compiler intuitive
optimizations and we get up to a factor
of seven speed up here on a four core
machine so I'm doing for time to
slightly controversial things that I
want to go onto this is very important
for the new runtime that we're working
on so it is a new runtime for the new
compiler and it has different requisites
and the runtime from the old compiler so
we've developing these two things at
some point we're going to need to put
them together so there are some topics
that we need to think about how one fits
into the other and how we want to move
forward want to use more modern tooling
and software techniques for the new
runtime and we want to retool the old
runtime so that we eventually we can
merge the two together so one of the
things we've been doing is looking at
machine complex functions in this in the
more recent C standards there are
machine precision complex functions as
part of a the c99 standard and that
means we can get things with
standardization of exceptions more
efficient and we can also remove some of
the our own implementations of these
functions from the runtime library so
here's an example of a good thing of
this library if you run this in
Mathematica you have the tangent of a
complex number where the really
imaginary parts are the maximum machine
number you'll get an overflow and that's
because in our implementation if you
look at this this form of how it would
be implemented we would see Oh in here
there's an intermediary exponential that
has it's not able to fit into a machine
number but in the seal in the C library
for this function it has a special case
for the asymptotics and so it's gonna
say well I don't really mind if it's
gonna overflow or not because I know
that the numerator and the denominator
are going to be the same size so
asymptotically it's going to go to 1 ok
and so in the new in the new version of
Mathematica you'll get it you'll get a
machine precision result for that
because the C library function
implementation had a special case that
wasn't in our in our library code
problematic thing though is when we come
to inverse trig functions ok so this is
the current situation that we have in
Mathematica if I switch to c 99 then i
get this situation here you'll see okay
all well and good these are exactly the
same these look similar but
unfortunately the sign of the real part
is different ok so the question is why
the difference if I had a bit more time
I'd let you think about it and maybe
come up with some ideas but it's kind of
complicated ok the reason goes back to
this paper from the 1980s called much
ado about nothing signed bit by kahan
who's the grandfather of floating-point
arithmetic
and I've called it a tale of two zeros
Dickensian version if anyone wants
something different but basically all
goes down to the fact that in I Triple E
754 arithmetic there are two zeros
there's plus zero and there's minus
serum and just a difference that zero
can have a different sign to that what
it does in Mathematica can cause that
difference now we've mainly been using I
Triple E aureus the tick for reals and
we've written our own functions complex
functions so this hasn't been an issue
before but if the c99 ID function
suddenly is relying on this behavior of
negative and positive zeros for its
branch cut structure you'll see here we
have the inverse hyperbolic sine
function sine function okay let's take
let's say that on this branch here like
we saw in the previous slide Mathematica
and the c99 function were the same okay
let's say that okay over here on this
branch cut they're the same value then
if my symmetry if I take minus that
value so I flip it over here in C in c99
code I'm gonna get a minus zero so I'm
going to flip from the branch being up
here to the branch being down here okay
because the zero is negative it's no
longer positive so the zero inherits the
sign of the of the negation but in
Mathematica zero is always up to
positive sign so we'd end up over here
and that's the difference between the
two mathematical instead of going down
here would go up here so this is a
slight incompatibility and it's
something that we need to resolve if
we're going to use these these are these
functions in a vectorized way so another
thing just the last few minutes it's
another thing that we need to discuss so
I've really throw this out there because
I want to know people's opinions I mean
like how horrible would it be if we
introduced sign zeroes in mathematica
matlab octave Python have them some
users get very confused by them I mean
it's a possibility
do we want speed or cost or do we prefer
to maintain you know the status quo that
we have at the moment so these are these
are sorts of things I want to throw out
there I want to discuss so another issue
is moving forwards with this runtime
library pushing the boundaries trying to
make it faster and faster what do we do
with underflow so underflow if you take
a machine number and you divide it by
two then you get an arbitrary precision
number it's no longer fits in the range
of of machine precision arithmetic now
unlike overflow underflow needs to be
determined for every single function so
arc sine cosine sine or whatever we need
to look at the expansion of that locally
around small values and determine
whether it's going to underflow and it
was you know a week or so of work to add
it for these for these complex trig
functions another thing is it causes a
slight stalling of the process of
pipeline when we do things in a
vectorized way because you have these if
statements if something's under float or
not and that stall that calls this kind
of branch prediction it affects the kind
of vectorization of the code as it's
going through in the runtime library
another horrible thing is under flow
calls it's unpacking of packed arrays so
you have one number in your big packed
array image or whatever the whole thing
gets unpacked and we have situations
already where under flow is always
disabled like when we solve PDS and endi
solve now in indie solve you have
transient transient phenomena you have
things varying on a very different time
scales but often over a very short
period so suddenly something could under
flow but it's not really physically
significant okay and if that that
suddenly caused your computation to slow
down in that small region you know at
the end of the day if it was zero or if
it was something very very tiny doesn't
really make a lot of difference it
doesn't affect the end solution so we
are paying a penalty for this here's
another example so let's take a
cumulative distribution function it's
like a probability asymptotically this
probability is going to turn to one okay
good so if I compute it you know for
quite a large value I get one but if I
compute it
a much larger value then I get a machine
underflow I go and compute something
with arbitrary precision and I get a
result back but now look like this is
smaller than one so what I have here in
mathematically is a non monotonically
non-decreasing function but like
increasing the argument here I get a
smaller number
okay so mathematically there's something
not quite right there - and apart from
the speed okay this is this is just much
much much slower the point is in this
context - like in Indy Sol it's not
really significant you know whether
whether the exponential of minus a
thousand was you know some very very
tiny number of zero effectively it's
zero in in this particular context and
another thing is when we were looking at
these vectorized functions some
libraries don't really do underflow very
well it's not something a lot of people
use so we were using this IPP library
something iliyan I found here when we
were testing we were testing the the
square root the vector square root
function from this IPP function so
here's the minimum machine number this
is a half this is - this is the maximum
machine number this is what what you
would get in C code the square root of
this number but the maximum machine
number here doesn't even have the first
digit correct in the in the Intel
library okay and and we're only using
the interlibrary with a mode that sets
underflow but it's but it's affected the
maximum machine number who knows why so
I mean we have reported this to Intel
they weren't aware of it it's been three
months now they're still working or
fixing it okay so these are quite
esoteric issues I mean I'm not I'm not
saying it's hot but it probably is a
very hard problem for them they've been
very you know receptive and responsive
of so so I don't want to say anything
like negative I'm just saying that we
are using things in supporting that
functionality that are kind of pushing
boundaries and it's something we should
think about another thing that we should
we should also think about is like
symbolic versus numerical evaluation we
do lots of transformations traditionally
in Mathematica with a view of symbolic
computation so we do simplifications we
were talking about lobs the other day
all right you you you you your inter log
of XY and evaluates the log of Y divided
by log of X okay a similar thing for the
square root the square root can evaluate
to you know power of something to the
half and this is another common one a
division or what looks like a division
is implemented as a multiplication of
the reciprocal these are vectors this is
two vector operations instead of us you
know doing it directly as a division and
also to you know different rounding
properties each of these symbolic forms
once it's been extended out has a
different numerical property you you
might get here like something of the
over of the order of machine epsilon
when your when your computer complex
square root or something so narrow
introduced by computing using a general
power instead of computing using a
square root and and and also here you
might get something that's off in the
last few bits because you're doing a
multiplication you have a multi but you
have a rounding error from the
reciprocation and you have a rounding
error from the multiplication let's skip
that one so I'm going pretty much over
time so let's just conclude here the run
time line beats the computational engine
of the mathematical kernel and compiler
we're putting a lot of effort into
developing it
we've improved some aspects of it like
thread scheduling for vector operations
we've added new optimize that vector
functions to improve improve performance
we're looking at compiler specific
things once they're widely supported in
different compilers to improve improve
performance we're trying to use you know
more modern more modern things like c99
standards for complex functions and at
the same time as we move towards this
new compiler that we're developing or
we're
we also need to think about some issues
that might be related to to you know
further developing and further pushing
the boundaries of performance there and
one would be this issue about signed
zeroes you know this issue of positive
and negative zero and I Triple E
arithmetic that we don't have we can't
select which of the which of the branch
cuts we're able to to choose in
Mathematica because we don't have the
possibility of a assign zero another one
is should we just abandon under flow
testing I mean should we just abandon it
and just say we're really now in a new
area of computation where we want to
push the boundaries of performance and
under flow testing is holding us back
another thing is I didn't talk about too
much as exceptional cases so in C you
would have something like zero to the
power of zero is one in Mathematica
you'll get an indeterminate for that
okay and that means that just is one
value here we can't use these vector
libraries for power because we don't
know if our vector is going to contain a
zero or not so maybe for machinery
static we should have different
exceptional cases that match the I
triple I Triple E arithmetic cases we
say machine arithmetic you know to do it
fast you have to match this standard and
maybe we should say that for machine
arithmetic we will adhere to that
standard another thing is we should look
at maybe reviewing some of the auto
simplification rules and some other
things that we're looking at is
improving the use of SIMD instructions
of vectorization and of course the run
time by B talk about that all 11:30
later so he might give you a glimpse of
that so thank you sorry for going all so
long
[Applause]